what sets valrant apart from other
tactical shooters are the abilities sure
there is precise gun play and shooting
definitely matters but with so many
tools at your disposal players have a
lot of ways to bamboozle their opponents
oh okay
he's running he's gonna swap it out
they'll never expect him to be here oh
my god magnum his brain is so big that's
why today we are honoring the most
brilliant outplays valorent has ever
seen but before we get to the genius i
want to remind you all to please sub to
the channel and turn on notifications if
you haven't done it yet we are almost at
2 million subs and you could be the
person who gets us there alright let's
get into it here are the top 10 200 iq
plays in valorant
kicking off our list is a place so smart
it looks stupid delete the vote end the
stream
it's time to go home
not like this
up against descendant masters berlin
hundred thieves orchestrated an
especially chaotic execute smack dab in
the middle of haven's b-site it's an
easy place to plant but it can be
difficult to hold that is of course
unless you're steel sitting a short with
an odin ego still stands though but the
diffuse is coming in wait the spray
oh
my
god how are we really seeing this right
now there's nothing they can do oh my
god
the lockdown as well will confirm it oh
we'll get detained here look at this
he's thought he got his hand on the
keyboard and maybe he should no he
doesn't leave there's no way man
stop it steal get him out of the game
this is
unbelievable
what have you done
steele knew they had to defuse because
the killjoy alt was about to pop and
basically end the round so he could
shoot right into a wall and wall bang
them to death and even though ascend
managed to slip in and diffuse between
reloads this is still one of the most
brilliant post plants valorant has ever
seen you can see the margaret was just
like oh oh no
[Laughter]
what a champion of the people a true
entertainer thanks for catching the
other half of that
slow walking its way into the ninth spot
on our list is proof that sometimes the
smartest play is to do nothing at all
you keep drinking whatever the hell that
is makes well i that was unbelievable
left in a 1v2 post plant against fun
plus phoenix in the grand finals of
blast switch invitational g2's mixwell
was screwed he had one smoke 70 hp and
an empty magazine but mixwell knew that
his opponents expected him to retreat to
either ct or the back of the site so he
dropped his smoke on the spike and just
waited he reloaded his gun inside the
cloud burst then popped out to surprise
his opponents with his massive brain and
it's now all on mixed well he's spent
all of his knives on 70 health he's got
the spike and i love this position try
and mix it up a bit
oh the paranoia comes out and they try
to spray him down he's playing out of
his own smoke as well but that will
quickly fade it doesn't stay around for
long he's off the side of it and both
players being screwed up could be a
massive problem here for him he starts
up on the shadow of football comes up
clutch
once again they cannot believe it look
at that so he trades out up or goes down
gets the plant but this he realizes
there's an over extension by shadow and
the spray the swing around to angel and
you can see it that was an absolutely
gorgeous clutch
dashing into number eight is a send so
full it literally stupefied everyone
involved and it was one bullet that's
all it was gonna take two clutches it's
the same reaction from the korean jet oh
my god during stage one of vct
challengers saya player was in an almost
unwinnable 1v3 against hundred thieves
they knew where he was and even though
saya player got one kill he was still
cornered outnumbered and nowhere near
the spike it seemed like there was
nowhere for him to go right
wrong
shred's only able to get one and now
it's a 1v3 for saya player it was only
pistols that they had to deal with saya
still dancing around this cage down to
25 hp tripwire in his way too dashing it
say a player
instead of rotating through garden or ct
sayo waited out his opponents and
pounced down their throats the second he
knew they were retreating long they had
no idea what hit them a red bull clutch
out of literally nowhere that is
outrageous sire
coming in hot at number seven is this
high-flying outplay from asana what in
the heavens is that the only recap that
that needs shift is me not saying
another word in our replay ops team just
replaying that in slow motion up against
exit and vct stage three challengers won
n a hundred thieves star fragger asuna
face down a full five man save round
execute which as any rifle wielding
anchor who's supposed to have the upper
hand will tell you
can be pretty scary so instead of taking
fights on his opponent's terms asana did
the one thing they'd never expect he
took the fight to them with zero utility
in the air
on a rope yeah there's not a whole lot
that exit can put to use in this round
awesome
goodness
ethan's also there's more down low
awesome wants to get aggressive just on
the ropes one in the seal team six is
this he's gonna find one at the right
click he's gonna confirm the ace
oh my goodness that's just stupid
unbelievable i've got no words for that
i've i've got nothing that's why i don't
charity
bobbing its way into the sixth spot on
our list is a juke from leaf so majestic
that if you blink you might just miss it
play of the tournament by leaf
absolutely disgusting facing down four
members in the finals of stage two
challengers n a cloud nine's leaf was
trapped on site with no choice but to
peek his way out of this situation one
gunfight at a time the push already
coming out of b is going to alert energy
that they can start making a big move on
a yeah adapts in a great position he
finds one on the way out as well just
down to leave but he can make this
costly this is where reynolds oh my god
this is where raiders are bred one more
yep now the duelists are starting to
come through
leave no way
leaf picked up two 1v1s on site but nrg
weren't about to let him have two more
so they double swung him from tree
alongside a perfectly timed fedex flash
but we saw the flash bombed backwards
blocked it with jenny and finalized one
of the cleanest aces of all time
choosing the correct targets
understanding the patience he had and
the time to work in sight with eu and
then this boom boom
it doesn't get any better than that
creeping along the halfway point on our
list is a movement play nothing short of
a masterful i can't get over like this
is just stupid i don't know what else to
say about that up against ascend in a
stage 1 challenger's match g2's nukia
lurked onto a site looking for a pick
trying to close off the rotate nukia
started to satchel boost himself to
heaven but right as he left the ground a
flying ulting rays came screaming at a
view hall with the rocket already headed
to heaven nukia should have been done
for nukia is he the playmaker that gets
g2 into this round again oh wow it's
just aerial movements this guy's a
gymnast nukia
that's right seeing the rocket flying at
him nukia dropped another satchel to
redirect his jump and perfectly dodged
the rocket mid-air the best part is that
nuka used a momentum to knock out asen's
three remaining members adding an ace to
the round for good measure and bone cold
has so much to do
one smoke available nukia now extends
from the showers and confirms his as he
finds all five
coming in at number four is an oldie but
a goodie do you need more convincing
that the man needs a pay pump
slight boost maybe some vacation time
left in a post plant 1v2 against tsm in
the first strike open qualifier cloud9
vice was sitting smack dab in the middle
of hookah with nothing but a sova arrow
and a dream knowing that he was about to
be held at gunpoint by wardell's op
weiss tossed out his recon bolt and
crossed the cover the issue is that he
wouldn't be able to pique the defuse
without getting deleted so he got
creative cloud nine just down to one
vice
in a 1v2 knows exactly what both of them
oh
my gosh how did he do that
you had to do it to him with the recon
bolt just had to this has been one
heck of a map
kicking off our top three is a play from
zom so brilliant it looks like cheating
zombs that's a nasty bit of work from
him and i love the methodical approach
in that he checked every other
possibility okay is it a crossfire from
backside maybe towards lobby main maybe
he's hit no staring down the barrel of a
1v2 post plant during sentinel's group
stage matchup against f4q at masters
berlin zombs knew he had one hell of a
sight clear ahead of him if he was going
to stick the defuse soms
looking for the way in
two towards the backside of sight as
well double stacked here tricky to swing
around on
what's he got in mind for it
there's the plan pulls zumba a little
closer 5k still just fine
toms needs to find this it's such a
tricky post plant position to defuse
high angle low angle he's trying to
clear all the other potentials and now
he's decided right this has to be at
this where they're gonna be i'm still
gonna try and get that one
that spray couldn't have been better
zombs already saw one player back sight
but the real genius was what came next
figuring the planter didn't cross to
garage he gravity weld back sight hoping
to bait a swing from behind pillar since
no one swung zombs instantly knew that
the second was either sitting on the
default plan spot or back sight with his
teammate after clearing default in
garage zombs realized they had to be
waiting for his swing together so he
tossed out a nova pulse and transferred
like a god again the phantom of the
happy yeah you can see they're pretty
happy about that one
poking its way into our number two spot
is vanity's cheeky big brained reminder
that sometimes it's actually smart to
bring a knife to a gunfight my god what
a way to finish the half right there
that guy's kill was everything facing
off against hundred thieves in the
semi-finals of na's champions tour lcq
vanity flanked his opponents for a free
kill before coming face to face with a
towering astra alt cosmic divide blocks
vision and it's bulletproof but you can
walk through it this means that in order
to clear corners you need to face check
them which is usually going to end in
you getting shot vanity knew all this he
knew that someone was probably sitting
on the other side of the wall at the
entrance to a long but again he couldn't
shoot them and if he crossed to pre-fire
he'd expose himself so he did the only
thing he could do he stabbed the wall to
figure out where his enemies were hiding
wall's about to drop as they're hearing
this one for a while now and it is on
the other side astra
damage oh my god what
vanity they can they're gonna win this
round he's gonna be able to play the
time he goes gonna have to work a
miracle here to be able to get this one
and cloud9 tie it up with a knife to
bring it six to six
and finally the most genius play
valorent has seen so far belongs to the
17 year old savior of n a the garden
exit were an ot at the nsg winner
championships and trent was the only man
left standing for the guard he was
trapped alone on cat exposed from every
angle and was facing down four members
of exxon this is what scientists call
unwinnable in the igl to support cryo
drops down so does aaron but aaron
actually the one to fall
after killing the killjoy market trent
was caught in a crossfire he spammed the
wall towards ct baited out the op shot
and tried to swing onto sova before
getting swung on himself and somehow he
came out alive yeah does him part and
now the shock darts bcj trying to play
legolas and trek stays alive now look at
the hp now it was a 1v2 trent sent his
owl drone to tag the jet ct and since he
knew the phoenix rotated to switch and
that any direct peak would be suicide he
fanned out further onto cat and executed
a pixel perfect wall bank was even
crazier is that because his recon dart
was up he secured himself a second look
or better yet a no look it's a 1v2 and
it's doable he spots out one wallbang
where is it it's a possibility trying to
light it up trent he finds it and now
it's a one versus one
unaware of the position of the other
last known in close to single bullet to
reveal the whooping it is trent
no
way this is how it started a free 2k for
a
second
it trent was damn near one hp
i mean the play around the utility it's
just perfection
all right folks that's our list if we
missed a brilliant valerian play that
deserved to be on here make sure to let
us know in the comments otherwise thanks
for watching and we'll see you next time
taking a heads-up fight with a judge
ain't the best of ideas and one by one's
even worse luckily he ended up with his
knife out trying to get some information
and well it comes at a pretty costly
price yeah he's got to clutch it yet
again but if anyone's gonna clutch
what